ALEX DANILO: I really
enjoy building websites
that run nicely on
all sorts of devices.
From phones to
tablets to desktop.
For me, one of the
hardest things to do well
is to debug how
my site would look
on different sized screens.
I'm sure you know
how hard that can be.
Hi, I'm Alex Danilo from the
Google Developer platform team.
And I'm going to show you a
great feature in the Chrome
DevTools called Device Mode.
Device Mode makes it super easy
to experiment with your content
and get your site looking
fantastic on any screen.
I've saved so much
time using Device Mode
that I get to spend a lot more
time making the perfect coffee.
Now, Device Mode lets you try
out your CSS media queries,
provides a bunch of
built in screen size
presets for lots
of devices, lets
you simulate retina displays
on a non-retinal device,
and even has a Network
Throttling feature that
lets you simulate slow
cellphone networks.
So let's take a quick
tour through the Device
Mode features to show you how
to get going quick [? smart. ?]
The first thing
you need to do is
click this little mobile phone
icon in Chrome Developer Tools
while looking at your site.
As soon as you've
done that, you'll
notice that your
site is displayed
in a completely different view.
Now is a good time to refresh
your browser window so that it
gets reloaded with the correct
viewport and user agent
string settings.
It's really easy to remember
to do that since you'll
be prompted to refresh it
in a little yellow warning
window at the top
of the DevTools.
Device Mode changes a
bunch of different things.
Like the user agent
string is modified
to match the device
it's simulating,
the viewport gets sized to be
the same as your target device,
the device pixel ratio gets
set to the correct value
for high DPI displays,
your text gets autosized
if the target does so,
and the content window
displays mobile scroll bars
that look the same as they
would on the real target device.
Not only that, but
touch events get
turned on so that your mouse no
longer triggers hover events.
So no [? colored ?] hover
CSS styles will be applied.
And the touch emulation delivers
events in the exact same order
as on a real device.
Now, the main control settings
you use in Device Mode
are here.
You can choose from a number
of different device preset
simply by selecting one of
the drop down device options.
You can also set your
viewport to a custom pixel
width and height by
changing the values shown.
It's easy to change the
device pixel ratio here,
which is also
super useful if you
want to test that
your site is supplying
retina optimized
images, for example.
You can also easily flip the
orientation from portrait
to landscape and back
with this rotation widget.
This makes it so easy to
try out different devices
and test that your media queries
are working as you'd expect.
Another really handy feature
are these drag handles.
Now using Device Mode, it's not
necessary to resize the browser
window to see the site in
different viewport sizes.
You can just grab these
handles and move them around
to see the size change.
Now, what you
might have noticed,
too, is that the pixel size
displayed in the main control
area updates to tell you
what the current size is.
Now one thing to note here is
if I choose a preset target
and then drag one of
the sizing handles,
it'll reset the preset,
since we no longer
match the size of the
target device we picked.
You might have noticed
this little icon at the top
here, as well.
What that does is enable
the media query inspector.
Each of the lines
here represents
the CSS media query
pixel breakpoints
that the browser's
detected in your content.
Now if you click
any of those bars,
the content window
resizes to match the media
query breakpoint size
so that you can quickly
see how media queries
effect layout.
This is so quick and
convenient it's fantastic.
But even better, you
can right click on them
to jump to where the media
query is defined in your CSS,
just in case you want to do
a quick edit of your styles.
Now, one of the main differences
between a desktop device
and a mobile device is the kind
of network it's connected to.
And Device Mode
provides a great feature
called Network Throttling
to help simulation
of different
network connections.
Now, as you can see,
there are a number
of different types
of networks supported
in the throttling drop down.
So typically when you're
testing load time on your site,
you'd use the dev tools
waterfall view, like this.
That tells us all about our page
load and resource load timings.
Now, if I choose a different
network speed simulation
and reload, you'll
see the page get
loaded under simulated
network conditions.
Now, as you can see
in our new waterfall,
it took a lot longer to load.
You can even set no
network connectivity
to help debug your site if
you expect it to work offline.
No more turning off of
your network required.
Now, even better, this
network throttling only
applies to the
currently opened tab,
so you can continue to use
your browser as normal,
since only the
tab being debugged
that is affected by
the network throttler.
Now, of course, since we're
simulating mobile devices,
chances are they're
touch enabled.
Device Mode enables proper touch
simulation using your mouse.
The content gets sent touch
events instead of mouse events.
So let's take a look at this
text with the Device Mode off.
Now, as you can see,
when I hover over it,
the text changes color.
If I turn Device Mode
on, no hover events
are sent to the content.
More importantly, the
order of touch events
sent to the content is identical
to a real device, which
makes it really easy to
debug your touch handlers.
There are even more
controls for you to explore.
From emulating hardware sensors
that are on your device,
changing the user agent
stylesheet, and plenty more.
You can also add screencast
from a connected device,
and view the rendered content
right inside DevTools.
Device Mode brings
really, really powerful
debugging capabilities
inside Chrome DevTools.
And it's something I'm sure
you can't wait to explore.
You'll find the links
to our documentation
here, and as always,
feel free to reach out
for more information
and feature requests.